i
[Música]
cuando escuchas la palabra poesía que es
lo primero que viene a tu mente
tal vez pienses en un caballero medieval
perdidamente enamorado de una doncella
recitando las palabras de amor o
escribiendo tristemente en la melancolía
de no ser amado por ella
la poesía sin embargo es mucho más que
eso es una forma de expresar todo
aquello que observamos y experimentamos
en todos los aspectos de nuestra vida
cada vivencia es un poema esperando ser
escrito
como cuando levantas la mirada y ves las
hojas de un árbol bailar al son del
viento
cuando un autor escribe el sol renueva
las cosas con su oro matinal en la mente
de cada persona que lee estas palabras
surge una idea algo que le permite
sentir la luz y el calor del sol y puede
ser algo tan cotidiano como el sol que
te acompaña todos los días al trabajo o
algo tan significativo como aquel
amanecer que te brindó la esperanza de
una nueva oportunidad
alguna vez has escuchado un poema en el
que con unas pocas pero muy bien
elegidas palabras el autor expresa algo
que tú también has sentido pensado o
incluso en el lado de ser así podemos
decir que ya sabes lo que es encontrarte
en un poema
cuando esto sucede la poesía se vuelve
un puente a través del tiempo y la
distancia porque sin importar cuándo ni
dónde alguien escribió esas palabras
cuando tú las leyes piensas
no soy la única que ha pensado esto no
soy el único que ha sentido esto
gustavo adolfo bécquer escribió mientras
el aire en su regazo lleve perfumes y
armonías mientras haya en el mundo
primavera habrá poesía
y tú probablemente te preguntes yo por
qué debería preocuparme de que dejará de
existir la poesía la realidad es que se
encuentra un poco amenazada por nuestro
acelerado ritmo de vida gradualmente
hemos ido perdiendo la capacidad de
apreciar las cosas y las personas que
están a nuestro alrededor no te ha
pasado que estás tan preocupada por
tener la foto perfecta para subir a las
redes sociales que no disfrutas el
regalo de la compañía y la vista que
están ante ti bueno pues la poesía es
una invitación a hacer una pausa
a abrir nuestros ojos nuestra mente y
nuestro corazón para ver la vida de una
forma más completa más profunda con su
economía de palabras y con su uso de
metáforas la poesía nos ayuda a ser más
creativos
nos hace pensar en imágenes
ahora bien tú crees que con todas esas
bondades que la poesía nos ofrece debe
estar guardada en libros esperando que
alguien vaya a buscarla no yo creo que
hay que llevar la poesía a los lugares
donde la gente vive día con día y para
ello me gustaría compartirles dos
proyectos que he realizado para acercar
la poesía a la gente
el primero pues sí andariega es un
proyecto hecho aquí en la ciudad de
mérida en el que hemos puesto poemas en
los autobuses del transporte público
las estrofas cuidadosamente
seleccionadas hablan de naturaleza de
ideas inspiradoras y de recuerdos de
experiencias sencillas y a la vez
significativas y tienen el propósito de
que al abordar el autobús en lugar de ir
clavados en la pantalla de sus celulares
las personas lean esas palabras y
empiecen a pensar empiecen a sentir y al
bajarse del autobús lleven con ellos
esta idea y con sus sentidos bien
despiertos puedan apreciar todo aquello
que salga a su paso durante el resto del
día
el segundo proyecto matices del mayab es
un proyecto que combinó fotografías y
poemas relacionados con colores lo que
hicimos fue imprimir en postres bien
grandes poemas y llevarlos a plazas
públicas lugares donde la gente pasaba
al salir del trabajo oa donde iba a
convivir en familia al principio la
gente se acercaba con curiosidad a mirar
las fotos a leer los poemas trataba de
encontrar la relación entre las palabras
y las imágenes
y hubo también quien se encontró a sí
mismo en un poema es decir que la
emoción expresada por ese poema resonó
en su alma
pero también le pedimos a la gente que
escribiera y que nos contara cuál era su
color favorito del lugar donde vivía
y sus respuestas las pusimos para que
otras personas también pudieran leerlas
cuando la poesía salió al encuentro de
la gente en esas plazas todos se
volvieron poetas y lectores de poesía
para mí es un hecho que la vida es mejor
cuando hay poesía porque todos podemos
encontrar en un poema algo que nos haga
pensar sentir recordar o incluso
cuestionarnos y porque todos tenemos
algo que decir
me encantaría que nos atreviéramos a
creer que todos podemos ser poetas
incluso cada uno de los aquí presentes y
yo espero que así sea porque el día que
reconozcamos que de músico poeta y loco
todos tenemos un poco seremos más
felices y este será un mundo mejor para
todos gracias
[Aplausos]